foreign
[Music]
Lucas electric these aren't just toys
this is the Lego Creator Palace Cinema
there's serious money makers that he
buys and sells for profit the biggest
online database of collectible Lego sets
lists 1.2 billion dollars worth of the
toys around the world you know Lego Tron
up here we're in the three to four
hundred dollar range this Lego Tie
Fighter 200 a piece is what these are
selling the returns that I typically
will see is somewhere between 150 to 250
percent on a Lego set researchers say
electric is one of tens of thousands who
concerned by the recent volatility of
stocks and bonds are betting on the
reliable returns from this tiny but
growing Market the average return on
other Collectibles like wines or art or
automobiles stamps hello generally lower
than they go this is Niche markets a
series that examines small lesser-known
markets that despite their size punch
well above their weight
[Music]
electric is an insurance broker in
Pennsylvania and grew up playing with
Lego I kind of got out of Lego obviously
like most people do
um but then when I had my first boy
Bruce we started building some Lego sets
and that's kind of what rekindled the
passion and kind of the memories
this nostalgic hobby with his children
turned into a lucrative investment
strategy when electric walked into a
Target about five years ago I saw a Lego
set a Lego Ninjago Destiny's Bounty and
I remember thinking to myself at that
time I could literally just take this
put it up online sell it and you know
double my money since then he says he's
invested around 65 000 into building a
collection of Legos most profitable sets
the toys in this room typically cost
anywhere from thirty dollars to over
five hundred dollars at stores
so this is the 1989 Batmobile this for
electric the most important factor in
Lego investing is knowing how to spot a
winning set you know you think Lego you
might think child but Lego is really
geared a lot of their sets nowadays
towards the adult collectors
larger sets like these Target the
growing community of adult fans of Lego
who call themselves a Falls
rather than toys to play with they're
usually looking for display pieces and
can afford these more expensive sets
you've got the informational plaque
you've got kind of this stand to display
some of the iconic figures from the
movie so it's a really beautiful set to
turn a profit on these kits electric
makes sure he gets in at a low price so
he scours the market for sets Lego is
about to retire or stop producing the
official Lego store and other retailers
usually sell them at a discount to clear
their stock sometimes as much as 40
percent off
this actually just retired this past
year and I ended up picking it up a
couple of them two or three of them for
like 200 a piece within just a short
period six to 12 months this has already
jumped up to 400 to 500 I believe is
what this is selling on eBay but in
order to make a larger profit electric
says it takes patience usually holding
sets for two to three years before
selling
[Music]
sealed that's what collectors looking
for you want to make sure you're storing
it on the right shelving you want to
make sure that you're keeping the
humidity low
electric says he spends two to five
hours a week on his Lego Investments and
while it's more time consuming than
other items in his portfolio he says his
Lego sets have seen the most stable
growth this year you don't get a lot of
fluctuation with the prices going way
down way up like we're obviously seeing
right now with the stock market it's
very volatile economists say that's
because the Lego Market moves more
slowly than traditional Investments when
some news come to the market or the
stock market reacts very quickly on the
same day Lego is much less liquid Market
Victoria durbinskaya is an associate
professor at the higher School of
economics University in Moscow since
2016 she's been specializing in the Lego
secondary or reselling Market analyzing
three decades of financial data about
the niche investment she says the law of
supply and demand helps Lego in the same
way as other Collectibles like luxury
watches or fine wine once a bottle of
wine is open
opened and drunk so it disappears from
the market right the same with Lego but
what gives Lego the advantage over other
Collectibles she says is its
affordability generally other
alternative Investments are more
expensive so the potential returns are
somehow lower I mean if Lego set
appreciates by five dollars if initially
its price was one dollar then it's a
huge return
the LEGO Group didn't respond to
requests for comment about the growth of
the resellers market and its impact on
the company's product strategy
there are times when you're going to get
you know box damage like that but
high-end Lego sets can come in thousands
of pieces some of which may be rare or
newly designed so buyers expect the
cardboard boxes that hold them to remain
sealed and in near perfect condition
when you buy them distantly on eBay or
in some other platform you cannot check
it so you need to be sure that it is
fully sealed because if a rare part is
missing that would be a very big problem
this niche market is also at the mercy
of Pop Culture Trends where the
franchises and themes investors buy
today may not be relevant years down the
road that's just kind of part of get
them doing business and investment
sometimes you win sometimes you lose a
little bit but you know typically if you
do it right it all shakes out in the end
[Music]